[Musik]
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
barbara hahlweg guten abend und
willkommen an meiner seite ist für den
sport legen eine antwort von mir auch
dieser nachrichten tag ist geprägt von
der flutkatastrophe
wir werden einen sehr langen atem
brauchen sagt kanzlerin merkel im
hochwassergebiet und verspricht
unbürokratische soforthilfe mit dem bus
in die flut regionen damit sich das
corona virus nicht ausbreiten können
sich die menschen hier impfen lassen
kurz trip ins all amazon gründer jeff
bezos fliegt mit dem ersten zahlenden
passagier für rund zehn minuten ins
weltall
zum zweiten mal innerhalb weniger tage
war die bundeskanzlerin im
katastrophengebiet erneut sagte sie
rasche hilfe zu man werde alles daran
setzen dass das geld schnell zu den
menschen kommt
sie hoffe das sei eine sache von tagen
diesmal war merkel in nordrhein
westfalen in bad münstereifel bei bonn
so sah der mittelalterliche ort vor der
katastrophe aus ein touristenmagnet mit
seiner fast vollständig erhaltenen
stadtmauer und den fachwerkhäusern
jetzt ist nahezu alles zerstört und
niemand weiß ob es jemals wieder so wird
wie zuvor
peter böhme
die kanzlerin und der ministerpräsident
von nrw im krisengebiet mitten in
deutschland dieses mal in bad
münstereifel gespräche mit helfern und
betroffenen der politische versuch sich
ein bild zu machen von einer
apokalyptischen lage es ist aber nicht
unbedingt so dass alle leute hier auf
die politprominenz gewartet habe
später mal und jeden tag bringen
ich denke es ist schon wichtig dass sie
hier war also sie muss sehen was hier
passiert ist und also was hier passiert
ist durch die das unwetter aber auch was
passiert seitdem das große große thema
ist natürlich wie geht's weiter und und
wann kommen gelder wie wie kann man
weitermachen also soforthilfemaßnahmen
japan morgen will das bundeskabinett
genau darüber beraten
das land nrw will die dann für sich
bewilligten gelder verdoppeln und armin
laschet verspricht die formulare und die
anträge müssen ganz simpel sein ganz
einfach sein und sie sollen noch in
dieser woche fertig sein damit recht
bald das aus zahlen der ersten gelder
beginnen kann einfach simpel schnell
skepsis bei diesem geschäftsmann dessen
hutgeschäft einem rohbau gleicht nicht
über corinna muss nichts gab
[Musik]
schon zwei jahren nichts verdient und
jetzt alles von bord die kanzlerin
spricht angesichts des trümmerfeldes von
entsetzlichen zuständen und sagt
dauerhafte hilfe zu aber es ist auch
sehr klar dass wir hier einen sehr
langen atem brauchen werden und deshalb
frau bürgermeisterin unter landrat wir
werden sie nicht nach kurzem vergessen
sondern wir werden uns immer wieder ein
bild darüber machen wie es mit dem
wiederaufbau steht und dieser
wiederaufbau wird wohl einige jahre
dauern
gehen wir nach rheinland pfalz die zahl
der toten steigt weiter auf jetzt 122
und in all den trümmern und problemen
wächst eine weitere sorge die angst vor
corona ausbrüchen im katastrophengebiet
marion geiger beginnt ihren bericht im
kreis ahrweiler in der gemeinde alten
nach nordwestlich von koblenz dort ist
die medizinische versorgung nach der
flut eine echte herausforderung
innerhalb von fünf minuten stand das
wasser kniehoch in der praxis von
zahnarzt werner jung in altena er kann
knapp raus aus der wilden flut in seiner
praxis aber ist alles kaputt
der 67 jährige wollte eigentlich noch
weitermachen doch nun steht die praxis
vor dem aus das machen
ich habe mich da also mittlerweile mit
abgefunden ist natürlich scheiße ab und
zu ist man natürlich mal so im waren
krank nachts muss ja nicht in all den
trümmern ist die medizinische versorgung
schwierig fürs nötigste sind im kreis
ahrweiler zwei mobile arztpraxen da
große sorge bereiten der einsatzleitung
die hygienischen verhältnisse denn
schlamm und flusswasser sind verseuchte
durch heizöl abwasser müll und
tierkadaver das wasser zu nutzen ist
gefährlich zudem wird befürchtet dass
corona virus könnte sich im chaos der
katastrophe unkontrolliert ausbreiten
deshalb ist seit mittag ein impf bus im
einsatz der andrang groß
ja ich habe meine erste impfung bekommen
um eine zweitimpfung wäre jetzt am
freitag gewesen und dies halt
ausgefallen weil das die praxis selber
abgesoffen ist ja und jetzt habe ich die
chance genutzt um eine zweite impfung
auf jeden fall zu bekommen
für den landkreis stehen inzwischen 2500
einsatzkräfte bereit sie reichen bei
weitem nicht aus um alle betroffenen zu
erreichen
ich weiß dass das etwas alles verzögert
kam aber ich bitte um verständnis so
viele kräfte hier heran zu ziehen
und ich muss sagen wenn sie zweieinhalb
tausend menschen haben wir hier ungefähr
im moment im einsatz
aber wenn sie die auf schadensgebiet man
sich anschauen
fallen die kaum auf doch es packen auch
viele privatpersonen beherzt mit an
sie wollen wie hier in dernau den
betroffenen helfen
das könnte es hätte auf einer von uns
sein können oder verwandtschaft oder
sonstwas und die menschen im aartal
werden noch viel unterstützung brauchen
unser reporter bobby serien ist seit
tagen im katastrophengebiet unterwegs
wie ist dein eindruck wie läuft die
hilfe vor ort bei der hilfe hier kommt
es ganz klar auf das private engagement
an die essensstände hier in den straßen
wurden aufgestellt von privatleuten oder
von privatfirmen ganz viele kipplaster
dich hier rein und rausfahren gehören zu
gartenbaubetrieben oder zu
schrotthändlern die kommen eigenständig
hierher laden den müll auf und bringen
den dann zur deponie was es vor ort
nicht gibt das haben wir mehrere
anwohnerinnen und anwohner erzählt ist
eine zentrale koordination und die wäre
wohl sehr wichtig damit man allen klar
ist womit man eigentlich anfängt was als
erstes abgearbeitet werden muss die
einen wünschen sich so eine koordination
ganz stark und die anderen sind nur noch
genervt und die sagen bis hierhin haben
wir alles alleine organisiert den rest
bekommen wir auch noch hin aber ob das
am ende so aufgeht ist natürlich eine
andere frage
das private engagement ist beeindruckend
aber leider ziehen solche katastrophen
ja nicht nur helfer an
tatsächlich haben uns einige menschen
hier erzählt dass es auch hier schon
schaulustige gegeben hat die allein zum
fotografieren hierher gekommen sind und
dann soll es auch plünderungen gegeben
habe
auch das ein grund warum einige menschen
weiter in ihren zum teil zerstörten
häusern wohnen und sie leuchten hier mit
hilfe eines generators in der nacht die
straße aus zur abschreckung
gewissermaßen und die die nicht hier
übernachten sind froh dass die polizei
nachts streife fährt kriterien aus bad
neuenahr ahrweiler vielen dank für diese
eindrücke hunderte soldatinnen und
soldaten sind derzeit im
katastropheneinsatz sie versuchen unter
anderem den menschen zu helfen die noch
immer extrem schwer zu erreichen sind
unser reporter stefan schlosser war
heute unterwegs in rheinland pfalz eine
brücke die zwei ortsteile verbindet ist
dort komplett zerstört die unterstützung
der bundeswehr dringend nötig nur mit
dem boot sind die beiden ortsteile von
recht miteinander verbunden
die bundeswehr als wassertaxi wie
vormals nur wenige meter breite hat sich
an dieser stelle einen neuen flusslauf
geschafft dennoch rein aus trümmern von
den häusern und der brücke und der
straße von einer gegenüber liegenden
die einzige brücke ans andere ufer von
der ahr weggerissen
die wassermassen haben sich in den ort
hinein gefressen mehrere häuser sind in
den fluten verschwunden
seit dem hochwasser vor sechs tagen sind
die menschen hier so gut wie
abgeschnitten
wir hatten ja keine verbindung hat
keinen kontakt zur außenwelt hat wir
haben familien auf der anderen seite
auch in der familie beschwert doch dass
hier die ist schwanger wir hatten keinen
kontakt zum vater zur schwiegertochter
jetzt ja das war brachte tag das
nötigste kommt bisher vor allem aus der
luft pausenlos sind helikopter im
einsatz bringen den menschen wasser
nahrung kleidung kraftstoff organisiert
wird die aktion vom nürburgring aus die
weltberühmte rennstrecke in der eifel
hat sich in wenigen tagen in ein
logistikzentrum verwandelt allein rund
25 tonnen fliegen die einsatzkräfte
jeden tag in entlegene regionen wie
andernorts auch ist die
hilfsbereitschaft in recht groß alle
räumen auf was aufzuräumen geht aber
schweres gerät ist bisher auf dieser
seite nicht angekommen es gibt keinen
weg hierher
die bundeswehr ist heute mit pionieren
vor ort unterrichtet eine behelfsbrücke
die erste feste verbindung über die a
wir sind so strukturiert und haben das
material dass wir das können wir tun es
gerne getreu unserem motto wir dienen in
deutschland wo wenn nicht hier ist
dieser spruch veritabler und unsere
männer und frauen sind motiviert und wir
tun unser bestes um der bevölkerung hier
helfen zu können
ab morgen soll die brücke befahrbar sein
sie wird die versorgung der menschen
viel einfacher macht
aber es ist nur ein weiterer kleiner
schritt es gibt noch so viel zu tun
die hochwasserkatastrophe ihre ursachen
und folgen damit beschäftigt sich ein
zdf themenabend ab viertel nach acht und
wenn sie für die menschen im flutgebiet
spenden wollen das aktionsbündnis
katastrophenhilfe hat ein spendenkonto
eingerichtet die iban lautet de 65 104
106 100 104 106 100 stichwort zdf
hochwasser
weitere informationen finden sie unter
spenden zdf.de und im zdf text auf seite
8 190
bisher sind bei der aktion rund zehn
millionen euro zusammengekommen
zu den corona zahlen in deutschland das
robert koch institut registrierte binnen
24 stunden 1183 neue fälle das sind 500
37 mehr als vor einer woche
34 todesfälle kamen im zusammenhang mit
dem virus hinzu die sieben tage
incidents steigt weiter auf 10,9 und das
impfen
inzwischen sind hierzulande 38,8
millionen menschen vollständig geimpft
das entspricht 46,7 prozent
am langsamsten ist sachs hier haben erst
knapp 43 prozent einen kompletten
impfschutz in bremen sind es über 52 die
sächsische landesregierung sucht nach
ursachen für die impfmüdigkeit und
versucht tempo zu machen
stefan kech die ärmel hochkrempeln gegen
die impfmüdigkeit der sachsen das wollen
politik wirtschaft und gewerkschaften
sie trafen sich zu einem sächsischen
impfgipfel wollen neue kampagnen starten
den überzeugungs turbo anwerfen
vor allem aber wollen sie einst ganz
deutlich machen
geimpft genesen getestet das wird bei
einer steigerung die gruppe sein die
ausgenommen sind von einschränkungen und
damit ist auch klar dass das
komfortabelste dieser drei varianten das
geimpft sein ist im skeptiker oder
zögerer zu erreichen ist nicht einfach
mit gutscheinen gelingt es manchmal oder
wie hier in chemnitz mit freikarten für
das fußballstadion
ich schaue mir gerne fußball und habe
mir gedacht ja wenn du die chance hast
dann nutze die auch gerne ich war selber
auch hin- und hergerissen
meine freundin zum beispiel will sich
nicht impfen lassen einfach weil sie
bedenken hat gegenüber dem impfstoff
oder den impfstoffen und es gibt
versuche mit materiellen anreizen
anstatt durch argumente zu überzeugen
sehen einige ärzte kritisch
das halte ich für völlig verfehlt weil
das zu einer konditionierung für die
zukunft führen wird und jeder wird in
zukunft worten ich mache immer ist eine
maßnahme für die gesellschaft wenn ich
dann auch was dafür kriege gegen die
mögliche vierte welle gäbe es nur ein
mittel
als sich der ärzte dann eben auch mit
einer impfpflicht die die politik
allerdings ablehnt am 20 juli 1944
scheiterte das attentat auf adolf hitler
heute wurde in berlin der
widerstandskämpfer um graf von
stauffenberg gedacht in der gedenkstätte
plötzensee riefen vertreter der
bundesregierung und des berliner senats
zur wachsamkeit und zur verteidigung der
demokratie auf zum gedenktag legten am
bendlerblock bundeswehr rekrutinnen und
rekruten ihr gelöbnis ab knapp vier
wochen nach dem messerangriff in
würzburg in ist der mutmaßliche täter in
einer psychiatrischen einrichtung
untergebracht worden
nach einschätzung der ermittler war der
somalia zum tatzeitpunkt möglicherweise
schuldunfähig
der verdacht eines islamistischen
hintergrund habe sich nicht erhärtet
sagen sie der mann hatte in einem
würzburger kaufhaus mit einem
küchenmesser auf mehreren menschen
eingestochen
dabei starben drei frauen acht weitere
menschen wurden verletzt
die eu-kommission hat polen ein
ultimatum gestellt im streit über die
unabhängigkeit der justiz des landes es
geht um die sogenannte disziplinarkammer
die richter und staatsanwälte entlassen
kann die kommission droht mit
geldstrafen wenn diese disziplinar kann
man nicht bis zum 16
august aufgelöst wird auch der
europäische gerichtshof hatte in dieser
sache gegen polen entschieden und jetzt
ins all das erobern gerade mehrere
milliardäre nach richard branson vor gut
einer woche hatte heute amazon gründer
jeff bezos seinen großen tag
kurz nach drei unserer zeit hob seine
rakete in texas ab außer besaß mit an
bord sein bruder die älteste astronautin
aller zeiten und der jüngste ganze
zweieinhalb minuten dauerte die reise
die auf kurze sicht den weltraum
tourismus ankurbeln und auf lange sicht
bemannte raumfahrt erleichtern könnte
benjamin daniel
60 jahre nach ihrer privaten
astronautinnen ausbildung wird wolf
angstraum war bei der nasa hatte sie
damals als frau keine chance um acht uhr
12 texanischer ortszeit startete sie nun
doch ins all
an bord der nur shepherd von
multimilliardär jeff bezos
es geht hier nicht um wettbewerb sondern
darum eine straße zu bauen so dass
künftige generationen unglaubliches mal
machen können
nach richard branson und jeff bezos will
im september auch elon musk in space
tourismus geschäft einsteigen
seine firma spacex ist schon seit jahren
in der raumfahrtbranche aktiv das
wettrennen um den weltraum sehen viele
kritisch gerade inmitten einer corona
und klimakrise
so zählt die raumfahrt zu den
emissionsrechten unternehmungen
überhaupt ein früherer us
arbeitsminister twittert dass
milliardäre ins all fliegen sei kein
zeichen von fortschritt aber wir haben
damit eine entwicklung angestoßen die
hoffentlich die hauben verdammt
tatsächlich voranbringt und den nutzen
für uns den täglichen nutzen erweitern
die geschichte hat oft gezeigt wer nach
den sternen greifen will muss groß
denken ob dies jedoch der richtige
zeitpunkt dafür ist bleibt umstritten
und wie so oft eine frage der
perspektive
der wichtigste deutsche literaturpreis
geht in diesem jahr an einen
österreicher der 38 jährige clemens j
sets wird mit dem georg büchner preis
ausgezeichnet der schriftsteller kunde
mit seinen romanen und erzählungen
menschliche grenzbereiche sagt die jury
seine drastik stiche ins herz unserer
gegenwart den mit 50.000 euro dotierten
preis bekommt er anfang november eines
der größten kulturprojekte deutschlands
kann jetzt auch von innen besichtigt
werden das berliner humboldtforum ist
erstmals für besucher geöffnet nach acht
jahren bauzeit und kosten von knapp 680
millionen euro
hinter der neu errichteten
schlossfassade gibt es zum start sechs
ausstellungen zu erkunden
unter anderem zur 800 jährigen
geschichte des schlosses und
kolonialzeit in den ersten 100 tagen ist
der eintritt frei
und jetzt zählen wir unter norbert der
countdown für tokio läuft ja noch genau
65 stunden und 43 minuten bis zur großen
eröffnungsfeier große worte fand heute
ioc präsident thomas bach olympia werde
den menschen vertrauen in die zukunft
geben
das olympische motto heißt jetzt
schneller höher stärker und gemeinsam
zum auftakt der ioc session in tokio
beschwört olympia chef thomas bach den
zusammenhalt wir möchten hier einen
besonderen schwerpunkt auf die
gemeinsamkeiten legen
doch von der verbundenheit mit dieser
olympischen idee entfernt sich zuvor der
topsponsor toyota bestätigt man werde
keine werbe spots mit olympia bezug
schalten und auch keinen
konzernvertreter zur eröffnungsfeier
schicken die furcht vor einem
imageschaden durch steigende corona
fallzahlen zu groß nur 20 prozent der
bevölkerung sind geimpft und die zahl
positiver corona tests im olympia umfeld
steigt laut organisationskomitee auf nun
67 seit anfang juli darunter fünf
athleten aber eine gute nachricht kommt
dann doch am dienstag aus dem
kaiserpalast naruhito wird zur
eröffnungszeremonie im nationalstadion
sein
ja die spiele werden zwar erst am
freitag offiziell eröffnet aber zuvor
starten bereits in den ballsportarten
die vorrunden das erste highlight am
donnerstag das deutsche fußball team
trifft auf brasilien den finalgegner von
2016 ungewöhnlich kleines der
spielerkreis den stefan kunst da um sich
scharen kann am spielort in yokohama 18
statt der möglichen 22 profis hat er nur
mitnehmen können
ein nachteil den sie ausgleichen wollen
mit spielfreude und teamgeist auch gegen
brasilien an man kann die deutsche
mannschaft erwarten die jung und frisch
ist auf jeden fall die sehr viel
spielfreude mitbringen würde aber auch
in den zweikämpfen konsequent ist dabei
kommen ihnen die brasilianer zum auftakt
ganz gelegen schließlich wollen sie so
schnell wie möglich umziehen vom hotel
in yokohama rüber ins olympische dorf
wenn mini coupé erster werden glaube ich
dann sind wir haben im olympischen dorf
und das ist unser ziel
zudem könnten sie revanche nehmen für
die niederlage ihrer vorgänger im finale
von rio damals im elfmeterschießen und
das war's vom sport jung frech dass ich
meine ansagen das wetter bleibt bis zum
wochenende schön im norden mit mehr
wolken im süden mit mehr sonne die
details hat gleich katja horneffer
christian sievers freut sich auf sie im
heute journal um viertel vor zehn
wir danken für ihr interesse wünschen
ihnen alles gute und sind morgen wieder
da
auf wiedersehen
[Musik]
guten abend von der nordseeküste da
zogen heute viele wolken zu uns rein die
brachten aber nur ein ganz kleines
bisschen wiese legen mit und richtung
südwesten da schien da häufig die sonne
da gab es nur so ganz kleine harmlose
quellwolken am oberrhein stiegen daher
die temperaturen bis 27 grad unter den
dichteren wolken blieb es bei 19 bis 21
grad kühler und richtig kühl wird die
nacht besonders hier in oberfranken in
der oberpfalz und schwaben oder auch im
westerwald da sinken die werte auf 9 bis
7 grad deutlich milder bleibt die nacht
entlang der küsten von nord- und ostsee
und das hat zwei gründe zum einen ist
das wasser fern nord und ostsee waren so
18 bis 23 grad und außerdem gibt es da
oben dichtere wolken die auch etwas warm
halten die bringen auch ein kleines
bisschen regen mit und dieser regen sie
dann morgen über tag etwas weiter nach
süden es ist wirklich nicht viel nur so
sprühen oder nieselregen
etwa südlich von thüringer wald rhön und
sauerland strahlt morgen wieder die
sonne und dort wird es auch wieder am
wärmsten am oberrhein erwarten uns auch
morgen wieder um die 27 grad im norden
ist es bei 20 bis 23 grad kühler und in
den nächsten tagen geht es mit diesem
ruhigen sommerwetter weiter erst ab
samstag drohen dann von westen einige
gewitter
guten abend